yadi may I invite you to say a few words
about
well
I think I will talk obviously about
music because but music is I think the
first language that we understand when
children is born he don't understand the
language or his mother his father any
language but he understand he feel the
love attenders from the mother through
the way the language is singing he
understand through the melody the way to
sing the words because every language
need the music to be understand without
the music of the words we will not know
what happens what changed you are to
feel yourself you want a good feeling
you are a good feeling so it's only the
music and this means the music I think
it's the first language that we use to
educate our children's because the music
is the first what goes with the with the
sense and everything and I also remember
their music it's the last thing that we
lost when we are the people they died
from from like Alzheimer like this
malady see you forgot everything they
still recognize the music and they still
they have pleasure to listen to music
until his last moment this is why the
music it's the first language then music
it's also the language of the memory
music exists only the life music it is
only when a singer play things and a
musician play as soon as finished even
you're recording as soon as finish
it doesn't success more what makes
possible do we remember something the
motion we are touch from melody from a
song from youth because this music has
makes your very happy of because they
they touch our sincerity and this we
have never forgot leave the same like
when we meet a person and this person
it's nice and it's we will also remember
this person we be knowing the life
thousands thousand hundred thousand
persons but we remember only we are only
remembering the good friends the people
that are close to us and they bring us
emotion and beauty I think also I think
this moment and the words of God there
who says so this songs
yep a de mémoire Salomon wah
yeah but is pretty because in fact the
senses all the things that we captured
we become transformed at with the sense
of the yeah the taste everything it
makes us living and then the memory it's
the central element from any
civilization without memory is no
progress it's no filter and one of the
principle I think disaster from the
human being is this lack of memory
because we repeat every 15 years of 50
years we repeat the same mistakes from
5,000 years ago and I think this reminds
me how we can help people for education
because we talk about all the education
with schools University but in reality
we have very short time to educate
some human being mostly what is
essential
it happens in that 10 first years the
most essential things that we can give
to our children
has to be done in this 10 plus years
after will be learning intellectually we
will learn languages with significant
things but the essential human elements
would this make human being different
from an animal are in the 10 yes
remember this season from Sauvage in the
19th century they have found sometimes
in the first children who was survived
because he was becoming the the food the
milk from work and these children's with
12 years 13 years working like animal
they was take bio bio I just specialized
and they have prayed to the gate is this
children it was impossible it was
impossibly have been never possible to
learn them the human image and learn to
be a human person because we have at the
beginning of our life we have a lot of
possibilities we are open we are we are
good where everything and every explains
if we have in the in our earlier time
make us like it
every bad experience close our
perception and makes us different and I
think for this is very important the
role of the education of the family I
think this is one of the most essential
and today I think my family's type to
other conditions they have to work the
mother or the father they have 2000 and
we gave the chills really to the small
places and I
that the first education it's this daily
contact daily talking positions sinking
back in music I'm making music it's very
important because I think music is still
there one of the most essential language
we can put music understand with
everybody in any culture even the very
different quarters
music we cannot live in music we can
live with language I can tell something
you wrong and maybe I can convince you
for this but when I play you will see
even the the most enough abet musically
a person will see if I don't play with
emotion if I don't play with my heart
and this is why music reminds very a
very important language a good have say
the music me sleep forgiveness and
mentioned ganancia Weldon verse in your
lip is as an album and they are see
other type is an can cement bond because
the music it's talks our hearts directly
and with music we can I think recover
the the pieces we need to live I think
in the days today that's around the
world it's a strong crisis it is more
and more hundred and thousand people
meeting with people they don't have
enough to eat
enough to have a real life with dignity
and millions of people are suffering
from from war from terrorism us and this
is shows that we are in enough phase in
the time of our civilization which is
not very positive
and we have the great advantages of
solutions of technology
of everything what is not essential and
essential things we done we're not not
able to resolve the most principal
problems which is understanding dialogue
and I think a my idea one of the
principal things that we have to put in
the endures in the education it's
understanding comprehension we have to
make people conscious to understand
other people we have to be free of of
prejudices we have to be free of
vanities we have to be free of arrogance
sometimes some years ago people were
saying oh we have to be tolerant yeah in
front of resistance in front of terrible
things to be tolerant it's positive but
somebody with stellar intolerant shows
already he's in a preference position I
am tolerant to you because you are here
down and I'm here but a real
understanding it's your understanding
from the
intercultural dialogue intercultural
dialogue means that we are accepting any
other culture it's has the same
possibilities that's our culture and
this is not what was happened in the end
oxidant war we was always thinking or we
have to the best music the first right
to the best technology the best degree
everything is the best and in
confronting other cultures we was always
saying yeah this is we say our first
world second or third world for
integrity and I think one of the
principal elements to found the dialogue
today with other cultures with Orion but
with other religions it's to be accept
there's no absolute through yep a Tahiti
observe every da but it can have his own
the living hell operation and all the
words that we have been having in in
Europe from the Middle Ages until until
the first civil war was religion was
religion war was as one of the principle
animals making the most strong violence
in Europe during sixteen seventeen
nineteen children and I think this is
one of the my conclusions I will say we
did the music because music brings us
happiness but also sensibility and the
capacity to be the Rev empathy and I
think also in this difficult world which
is very very complicated to live it's
been very difficult to live without
peace in a world full of violence and
crisis but without peace in our heart
it's impossible to learn to live and the
only things they bring peace in our
heart it's love music thank